so we're told here the four corners of a
rectangle are located at the points one
comma one
one comma six
nine comma six and nine comma one
plot the four corners of the rectangle
on the coordinate plane below and they
gave us these four points and we can
move them around with our mouse or our
finger depending on what type of a
computer we are using and so let's just
go point by point and plot the green
points at those points
so the first one is one comma one and
remember the first coordinate is our x
coordinate the second coordinate is our
y coordinate so the first coordinate
tells us how far do we move to the right
of the origin so it's one and then the
second coordinate the y coordinate tells
us how far to move up from the origin so
that's also a one so one comma one
the next point is one comma six x
coordinate is one
so we move one to the right of the
origin and then the y coordinate is six
so we move six
up and notice it's at the intersection
of the line or is it the intersection of
when y equals six
and x equals one this is one
comma 6.
all right now we have 9 comma 6.
so
let's see if we take our if we have x
equals 9 right over there and y is equal
to 6 so we'd go up 6. so notice y is now
equal to 6
and we have one last point to plot
9 comma 1.
so when x is 9
y is 1. we go 9 to the right or we're
right above x equals 9 and then we go up
one this is nine comma one and there you
have it we have the four corners of our
rectangle then they say what is the
height of the rectangle
well if you imagine a rectangle right
over here the height would be the
distance between that point and this
point or the distance between that point
and that point and so what is the
distance between these points
let's see they're on they both have the
same x coordinate
and this one is at y equals 6. this is
at y equals one so this is five higher
than this one so the height is five
and we could also count it you can see
one
two
three
four
five